-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night".
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
appeared last night
at the Grammy Awards.
It was gonna be Joe,
but he's not trusted
with classified material.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set
tomorrow to deliver
his State of the Union address,
and it's not a great sign
that the best he can say is,
"The state of our union
is balloon-free."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden told reporters
over the weekend
that he ordered the military
to shoot down the suspected
Chinese spy balloon, which
must've been tough,
'cause if anyone loves balloons,
it's this guy.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report
from Bloomberg News,
New York Congressman
George Santos
once claimed to have been a
producer on the Broadway musical
"Spider-Man: Turn off the Dark".
Another obvious lie,
because if you saw that show,
you know it didn't have
producers.
[ Laughter ]
At an event at the White House
last week,
celebrating
the 30th anniversary of the
Family and Medical Leave Act,
former President Bill Clinton
said that he has more people
bring up this law than, quote,
"any other specific thing
he did."
Well, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like it's the second.
That's like OJ saying
most people bring up
his Hertz commercials.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Canada are
searching for two suspects
who were seen driving
a stolen car
through a shopping mall.
Whoa!
If it was the '90s,
they could've killed someone.
[ Laughter ]
It's such a fancy
abandoned mall.
According to a new study,
Florida, last year,
experienced more lightning
strikes than any other state,
which might mean that even God
is getting tired of waiting
for Merrick Garland.
[ Laughter ]
The Rock & Roll Hall of Fame has
announced this year's
class of nominees.
It's the one hall of fame
that understands
that performance-enhancing drugs
are just part of the game.
[ Laughter ]
A federal judge in Oklahoma
recently ruled
that a law prohibiting marijuana
users from owning guns
is unconstitutional.
It makes sense, because by
the time they find their gun,
they forgot what
they were mad about.
[ Laughter ]
Producers have released
a trailer for a new reality show
about actor Sylvester Stallone
and his family.
And, yeah, you're probably gonna
need the captions on.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Cambodia recently
built a home
modeled after an airplane,
and now he's finally
ready to sit back, relax,
and recline his armchair
three inches.
And finally, in honor
of Valentine's Day,
the restaurant chain
Cracker Barrel has launched
a new contest that'll give five
couples free food for a year
if they get engaged
at the restaurant.
Also, doing a promotion
for newly engaged couples
at Cracker Barrel --
divorce attorneys.
[ Laughter ]
Bless your heart, but take
a card just in case.
That was a monologue, everybody.